- Welcome back y'all.
I'm here with the cast of
Book Club The Next Chapter,
with Jane Fonda, Candice Bergen,
Diane Keaton and Mary Steenburgen.
(audience cheers)
So we're gonna go through
some of our personal
book club picks in a moment.
But first, do y'all prefer
fiction or non-fiction?
Like what's your preference usually?
- Non-fiction.
- Non-fiction?
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I just feel life is so short
and there's so much to learn.
So, I'm non-fiction gal.
- What about you, Candice?
- I agree non-fiction.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- But Mary put me onto a
fiction book that I loved.
What was it? A Russian-
- Oh, A Gentleman in
Moscow by Amor Towles.
- [Candice] A Gentleman in Moscow.
- Yeah, it was a great read.
- [Mary] I love that book
and I actually got to meet him
'cause I kind of fangirled out and
- [Kelly] I love that.
- wanted to meet him
and he's wonderful.
Yeah, he's a great writer.
- So do you generally gravitate
towards fiction or non-fiction?
- Well, I read non-fiction because
Jane sends me books and
tells me this is good
and you should read this.
So I'm trying to keep up with
the Jane Fonda reading list
but when I go buy books,
it's usually fiction.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I love stories, you know.
- I love escapism in that sense too.
It's nice, yeah.
What about you, Diane?
What do you generally float towards?
- Yeah, Diane.
- That's Diane, that's
you, that's your name.
- [Mary] She's busy writing them.
- No, no.
I love visuals.
I like books with like,
lots of beautiful images.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And I'm addicted to that
and I have a lot of it.
So if you wanna come to my house
and look at my pictures.
- Oh, say yes to that.
- You know her library's black and white.
- [Kelly] That's, so-
- All the books are either
black and white, right?
- Oh really?
Like you rewrap them?
- They're not all black or white, no.
I'm not quite that bad,
but I like it.
(Kelly laughs)
- I, it's so true.
I worked with this photographer,
Brian Bowen Smith,
and he had a book
and literally the
pictures tell such a story
and it's so cool.
And how you capture like,
people like the story in their eyes,
like their movement,
anything like slight,
like that is so moving.
I agree.
That's- nobody usually answers with that.
That's nice.
Well, we asked you before the show
about books that you'd pick
as your own book club selection.
So let's start with Mary.
Mary, what's, you picked
A Gentleman in Moscow.
- [Mary] A Gentleman in Moscow.
I also, if I go back
I loved books like Cry,
the Beloved Country
and I was glad to be able
to read that in school.
- That's awesome.
Okay, I love that book.
What about you Diane?
What did you choose?
- You just did, you did me.
Move on.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- Did you not pick a book?
You picked a picture one.
Okay, okay, okay.
- Yeah, that's okay.
- I'm not sure that counts.
- Well, if it doesn't count, it's okay.
- [Kelly] It's okay.
We'll move on.
Candice, what about you?
- Me, I would pick Passage to India.
- Okay. Right on.
Why do you love that so much?
Why would you recommend?
- Because I love the feeling
of the dust and the schmutz
and the, and that you
get to know India and
and these incredible characters
and that it's beautifully written and um-
- Seems descriptive.
Yeah.
That's nice.
What about you? Like,
what's your book, you pick?
- Well it so happens. I like
the book I wrote mostly.
- Love you.
(Kelly laughs)
- I've written a number of
books. (audience cheers)
- [Kelly] I love it. Oh,
this is an important one.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
What can I do?
The path
- [Jane] I was very depressed
because what's happening
to the planet with the climate crisis.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And so I went to DC
and got arrested a bunch of times.
- [Kelly] Good for you.
Good for you.
(audience cheers)
- Turned 82 in jail and um
- Did you really?
- [Jane] Yeah.
- You're my hero.
- I figured that if I
could turn 82 in jail
a lot of people would say, well God
if she could do it, I'm
gonna, I'm gonna try.
We've gotta move from
being concerned about
climate to taking action about climate.
We're running out of time.
And so I wrote this book.
(audience claps)
- [Kelly] I love It.
- Describing how, you know,
hope is so interesting.
It's very different than optimism.
Optimism's everything's gonna be okay,
but you don't do anything to make it so.
Hope is like action with
its sleeve rolled up.
- [Kelly] Powerful.
- Hope is, you know, don't you
Greta Thunberg said something great.
Don't go looking for hope.
Look for action and hope will be there.
And that's what this book is about.
- Wow.
What a great line.
Yeah.
- It's called, it's called
What Can I Do? My Path From
Climate Despair to Action.
I encourage everyone
- And it's brilliant.
It's brilliant.
- It's very good, easy read
and full of information about what to do.
- All right.
I like it.
So Mary, you mentioned
a gentleman in Moscow,
so what do you love about it though?
What do you, why did
you recommend the book?
Why do you recommend it for people?
- It, well, I guess
because of what we do for a living.
I love the creation of characters
and he just created such
a totally unique character
in a unique world.
And it was a story I'd never
heard anything like it before.
- Fresh.
Yeah.
- Very magical book.
I just did wanna say
about Jane's book that
the thing I love about that
is big and small things,
including things nobody
had ever said before
that you can do for the climate.
Like in terms of what you invest in
and what you know and banking
and everything else.
It's such a brilliant book
about what you as a person can do.
- Thank you, Mary.
- [Mary] It's true.
- [Candace] Yeah.
- It's helpful.
That's what's great about it.
All right, everybody.
Book Club: The Next Chapter
is in theaters on May 12th
- Directors right there.
(audience cheers)
(Kelly makes alarm noise)
And Focus Teachers is giving everyone
in the audience a pair of
tickets to go see the movie.
(audience cheers)
So, like I said earlier
last year I launched a new initiative.
It's called Stranger Reads.
(upbeat music)
♪ Stranger Reads ♪
We're inviting everyone to step
outside our reading preferences
and discover books we'd
otherwise never pick up.
Often these book recommendations
come from total strangers.
It's happened to me multiple times
and I've loved every book.
Has this ever happened to you?
Have you ever seen
somebody reading something
and they're so into it
and you're like, what are you reading?
I've done that a lot.
Have you never done that?
- Yes.
- Okay.
Thank you.
Thank you, Candice. The last
time we did Stranger Reads,
my recommendation came from
Nobel Prize winning humanitarian,
Malala Yousafzai of all people.
It was incredible.
Check this out.
Malala, I was curious if you
wanted to share a book with me
and I would share one of my
favorites with you today.
- Of course, I would love
to share a book with you.
Last year, my Literary
book club had this memoir
called Aftershocks by a
debut author Nadia Owusu.
And she is abandoned by
her mother at age two
and orphaned by her, you know,
when her father dies at age 13.
And this is about how
this young woman has to
create her own home and
her own place in the world
and the strength and
courage it takes to do that.
And I think it would really resonate
with you and all your viewers, Kelly.
So I hope you would enjoy that.
- Oh I love it.
(audience claps)
She's so cool, y'all.
Now I have another book I wanna recommend.
It's called Genius of Place.
It's the Life of Frederick
Law Olmsted by Justin Martin.
I love this book.
I actually was reading a fiction book
and with my mother we
were reading this series
and it was fictional
but it had historical characters in it.
And so I googled this person because
of this fiction book I was reading,
Sarafina and The Twisted
Staff, something like that.
And it led me down this whole path
because I have a ranch
and I love land.
I think we should leave most of it alone,
again as much as possible.
But, so he's known
as the father of landscape architecture
and he's also known
- Central Park.
- Yeah for Central Park.
Most of the major parks here.
But also even more importantly
he, the Vanderbilt,
several wealthier people
back then were actually,
he was the leader of why
we have national parks.
Like it's, which is incredible
because I think what's so important
about Central Park that
you just brought up
is the thing I love
about learning is he was,
it was very cool
because in the time it was
all for the wealthy, right?
It was all for the higher ups.
They got to enjoy these beautiful parks
or gardens or things.
And his whole goal what,
and he won a contest
with this other French
architect to actually,
to actually, I'm giving you
the whole book right now.
But anyway, he won this contest
and it was so cool because he
wanted it to be for everyone.
It was for all walks of people,
all walks of life, all culture.
It was, which is pretty
progressive thinking,
you know at the time
because most of the people paying for it
were the wealthier people.
- Yeah.
- So it was, it's just really cool.
And I thought you can
learn a lot from someone
that you don't know, but
had such a well-lived life
and had all these
different journeys to get
to being this huge person for us.
- Did you see the documentary about him?
- I haven't, but I've heard of it.
But I haven't seen it yet, but I want to
- You know, I made a movie
in Connecticut once and I
I used to run in those days
and I was running in a park
and I could tell by the
way the park was designed,
I said Olmsted designed
this and I was right.
Yeah, you can tell
- It's very innovative.
I just think it's incredible
how people's minds think
like that artistically.
Mine does not.
But now let's get to the
books from my audience.
Everyone brought something they cherish
and want to pass on.
Caitlin has a recommendation.
Caitlin, what's your book?
- I brought The Courage to be Disliked,
which when you talked about
your twenties being rough,
I had some rough twenties.
And this book really, it's
about freeing yourself
from the judgment of others
and freeing yourself from
the judgment of yourself.
I'm going to be 35 this year,
I'm getting married,
I just started a new job,
and I feel like this book
was a complete 180 for me
in order to find my own
happiness within myself.
So I recommend
- Congratulations on all
the freshness in your life.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you.
Thank you.
- Yeah, but we also have Tamika,
so Tamika, what's your book?
- It's The Secret Lives of
Church Ladies by Deesha Philyaw.
And I'm a general manager
at a black-owned bookstore
in Los Angeles called Reparations Club.
And this was definitely
one of our best sellers.
It deals with the interior lives
of black women and
femmes around the church.
And you don't have to
be an avid churchgoer
in order to get into it
because it really deals with the morality
and some of the double
standards that exist
when we apply them to our like real lives.
There is some comedy in here,
there are intergenerational
conversations happening,
there is desire, there's queerness,
and it's just an amazing,
it's a beautiful, beautiful book.
It gives honor to the black church
and the role that it plays
in the black community while
also interrogating it deeply
and how it sometimes contradicts
with the ways in which we
were, which we show up.
And I deeply recommend it to everyone.
- Wow.
Yeah.
Great job you guys.
(audience claps)
Well have either of you
read each other's books.
Have either of you read those?
- No.
- Are you willing to
switch and try it out?
I like it.
Well, let's go ahead.
They're swapped, they're
gonna switch books
and now everyone, it's
time to switch books.
So turn to someone near you
if you haven't read the
book that they're holding.
Everybody has to exchange books.
I don't care who it's with,
but read a different book that
and even if you think you
won't find it interesting.
I see Shel Silverstein up there.
That's amazing.
(Kelly laughs)
Is that where the sidewalk ends?
I love that y'all picked that.
So much more reading for us all to do.
And I love it to be part of
our Stranger Reads campaign
and exchange your favorite
book titles with others.
Just head to our show's
Insta Story right now.
You're welcome in advance.